je suis sûr que vous connaissez ce truc
vous vous endormez et tout d'un coup
vous avez l'impression que vous tombez
dans le vide et vous vous réveillez en
sursaut c'est nul comme blague pourquoi
on fait ça oui j'ai un bouton sur le nez
tu vas faire quoi en fait avant de
dormir vraiment on passe par une phase
pendant laquelle notre corps se met en
mode avion tout ralenti petit à petit
les ondes de notre cerveau notre cœur
notre respiration et tous nos muscles se
détendent sauf que parfois ça se fait un
peu en décalé notre corps s'endort avant
notre cerveau du coup ok on est presque
endormi mais notre esprit est encore un
peu lucide donc on se rend compte que
nos muses se relâch rapidement et ça
nous donne cette sensation flippante
qu'on tombe mais en fait on bouge pas
c'est jquon vient tout et la réflexe
notre cerveau il se dit oh [__] on est
en train de tomber faut faire quelque
chose alors hop il contracte les muscles
du coup on sursaute du coup on se
réveille ah bravo le cerveau génial ça
s'appelle une hallucination hypnagogique
oui le mot compliqué c'est cadeau c'est
pour Péchot